are you sure it's Valyrian steel it's
wasted on a [ __ ] I've forfeited the
right to claim this soul
it's yours it serve you well and your
children after you hi everyone its
charlie I've gotten a lot of questions
about where all the Valyrian steel
weapons are on the show in season 8
episode 1 there are a lot of main
characters that have them they're a
couple really big ones that we haven't
seen on the show yet that they might
choose to bring into the season and
there's the X Factor of Gendry now in
Samwell with all those books on how to
fashion dragonglass and brand Stark who
has the knowledge of how to forge
Valyrian steel we've got less than a
week to go before the premiere is only
gonna get crazier if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos I'll be doing episode
videos all season long we're also doing
a weekly HBO now giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so I just
broke this down like a top 10 list there
are obviously way more than 10 Valyrian
steel swords and more Valyrian items
suits of armor other things made of
Valyrian steel in the series so some of
these I just combined but starting with
number 10 Jon Snow as you known as had a
long cloth for several seasons now given
to him by the old bear jr. Mormon who
refashioned the hilt from its original
bear design to a white wolf design
denoting Jon Snow's house stark change
the pommel from a bear to a wolf
they still Lanka recently John tried to
give it back to Jorah Mormont's easin 7
when they met north of the wall as it
was the honorable thing to do Valyrian
steel swords are extremely rare in
present day it almost always are passed
down within households as near priceless
heirlooms
so Jorah told John to keep it as he lost
all rights to it when he started selling
his own vassals into slavery as he said
during the clip may this protect you
your family and your children to come 9
though very important we see Jorah
Mormont in the season 8 trailer with
hearts bein on his hip meaning that at
some point before the big Battle of
Winterfell Samwell gives it to him to
use Hart's Bain is the ancestral house
Tarly blade that Sam will join back
during season 6 after his father randyll
Tarly told him off with Gilly Jorah is
on my death predictions list for this
season so if he falls in battle at some
point the sword would pass back to Sam
well by rights eight Brienne of Tarth
still has earth keeper one-half of Ned
Stark's form of Valyrian greatsword I
you can see it attached to her hip here
on the front line standing next to pod
at the Battle of Winterfell with all the
Knights of the Vale behind them that was
given to her by Jaime Lannister along
with her special suit of armor back
during season 4 when he tasked her with
finding Sansa Stark and protecting her
when she eventually completed her
mission she tried to give it back to
Jaime but he told her to keep it as a
way of showing her how much he respected
her in how much he cared about her this
is actually really important setup for
payoffs during season eight because the
way the actors talked about that scene
Nikolaj coster-waldau says that he was
playing the moment as if it were Jaime
giving her his heart and the sword was
just a metaphor for that so cannot wait
for that reunion but should Brienne
survive season age she would just
continue to keep Oathkeeper and pass it
down to her future potential children or
someone of her choosing 7 Jaime
Lannister has been wielding widow's wail
the other half of Ned Stark's Valyrian
greatsword ice you could call his in
Brienne's reunion two halves made one
two hearts made one because of the
metaphor of their relationship but also
two halves of one sword brought back
together but regardless of who lives or
dies I don't think that anyone will ever
reforge eyes from both keeper and widows
will they'll just continue to be used as
two separate swords what happened with
widow's wail a couple seasons ago though
is that when Joffrey died it was buried
with him but then quickly after that
Tywin Lannister had the sword removed
from his grave before he was killed by
tearing at the end of season 4 the sword
was taken to Casterly Rock for
safekeeping just waiting for the next
Lannister heir or for Jaime to formally
become tywin's heir not such a big
secret that Tywin Lannister had tried to
get Jaime to renounce his vows as a
member of the Kingsguard so that he
could formally pass his title in
Casterly Rock with all their possessions
to him as his traditional heir
oh you'll return to Casterly Rock and
rule in my stead Jaime is on my death
predictions list during season eight
though so if or when he dies widows wail
would pass to Tyrion first and if Tyrion
also dies because he's starting to
approach my death predictions list then
it would also be possible for Jon Snow
or Sansa Stark to take it back as
time--when Lannister technically stole
it from Ned Stark in the first place so
technically the blade belongs to House
Stark where did you get this much
Valyrian steel from someone who no
longer had
of it six aureus dark still has the
cat's-paws Valyrian dagger with the
dragon bone in ruby hilt given to her by
bran Stark during season seven because
as he said it would be wasted on a
[ __ ] Arya Stark is an assassin now by
trade so if anyone was gonna wield the
dagger that had been affectionately
named after an assassin back during
season one it would be her there are a
lot of theories about the true name of
that dagger and where it came from
originally where Littlefinger got it
from because the exact same design shows
up in Sam Wells book on Targaryen
history in dragonglass that book is
probably going to help Gendry make all
those dragon glass weapons during season
eight there are a lot of other Valyrian
steel weapons items and armor in
present-day that belong to other
characters who were either still alive
or there book characters that the TV
show has either changed or not done yet
so number five lady forlorn is a
Valyrian steel sword belonging to Lin
Corbray head of house Corbray of the
Vale he's on Littlefinger's payroll in
the books the last we saw of him was
when Littlefinger brought Sansa to the
Vale the TV show has done a version of
the character called Vance Corbray which
is sort of a reference to book Flynn
Corbray but there was no mention on the
TV show of him possessing the ancestral
balerion blade house Corbray so
potentially it exists in their family
for dark sister one of the other most
famous Valyrian steel swords was one of
the original Valyrian blades belonging
to a con the conquerors sister Visenya
sister wife I should say its last known
possessor was the Bloodraven aka Brendan
rivers also known as the three-eyed
Raven who you saw in the TV show George
R Martin has supported the theory that
he took it with him when he took the
black originally which was at the same
time that maester aemon took the black
as a younger person but if you're
confused about their relationship the
three-eyed Raven was the great uncle of
maester aemon so when this person the
Bloodraven took the black he was about
58 years old so he was a very old member
of the Nights Watch compared to maester
aemon who was a young man he eventually
rose to become Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch but then one day just
disappeared while ranging north of the
wall it's believed that he answered the
call of the children of the forest to
become the three-eyed Raven and he would
have had dark sister with him when he
did that so technically the sword dark
sister should have been in the
three-eyed Raven
cave beneath the weirwood but the show
didn't really get into his personal
history they didn't get into the
Bloodraven of it all
so technically dark sister is still out
there somewhere
three I get a lot of questions about
this there's the Valyrian steel suit of
armor worn by euron greyjoy in iran
Greyjoy's fever dream vision during
winds of winter the only reason that we
know about this is because George art
Martin would read excerpts of winds of
winter and in one of these excerpts he's
reading a vision that Aaron Greyjoy is
happening is a future timeline where
euron greyjoy
is sitting on the Iron Throne in a
Valyrian steel suit of armor the throne
resting on top of a mountain of skulls
in the gods are all impaled on the Iron
Throne
so it's air on the dam fair having this
darkest timeline apocalyptic nightmare
vision of what might come to pass should
Euron be successful in his quest to take
the Iron Throne I do not expect the TV
show to take things quite that far
because you're on and the Ironborn are
much bigger characters in the books and
they are in the TV show right now but
number two there are all kinds of
missing blades and other types of
Valyrian steel weapons and items which
appear in the books but we've not seen
on the show yet like the Valyrian steel
horn dragon binder that you're on
Greyjoy possesses in the books that he
may or may not use against one of
Daenerys dragons in the future the way
the Qyburn has been using the Scorpions
to take down two nurses dragons there's
the ancestral blade of Aegon the
conquerer black fire last seen in the
possession of the golden company heirs
to house Blackfyre many many years ago
but has been lost since the Blackfyre
rebellion so potentially it's somewhere
in the east they could choose to do it
on the TV show but it's been so long
that I wouldn't hold out hope for that
there's bright roars the ancestral blade
of House Lannister which was lost when
one of their ancestors named King Tommen
of the rock sailed on an expedition to
the ruins of ancient Valyria and was
never seen again in present-day Tyrians
uncle Jerry and Lannister Tywin's
younger brother went looking for it also
never to be heard from again and even
though I get a lot of questions about
what's going on with Arthur Danes
special sword dawn that's not a Valyrian
steel sword it's made from a meteorite
but it's a great sword just like Ned
Stark's ice the version the TV show went
with was a single-handed blade so that
Arthur Dayne could be extra badass dual
wielding against young Ned Stark during
that Robert's rebellion flashback
and now it begins because it was crafted
from a fallen meteorite the sword was
said to be as strong as a Valyrian steel
and it glowed with a milky white color
Ned Stark took the blade and Arthur
Danes remains after he was killed in
battle back to Starfall his family's
home and he's waiting for an heir to
pick it up again there is an heir named
Eric Dane in the books in present-day
who could pick it up but the show has
not done that character yet so I don't
expect to see dawn on the TV show again
in present day but number one there's
the issue of Gendry forging special
dragonglass weapons for everyone during
season 8 the actor Joe Dempsey said the
Gentry has a fairly predictable role in
the first part of the season meaning
that he'll probably be using the
instructions from Sam wells book on
dragon glass to learn how to fashion
weapons from it arrowheads spears for
the unsold special weapons like axes war
hammers maybe a few other surprises we
also learned that he's gonna make
himself a special new weapon to replace
the war hammer he made during season 7
when he ran that marathon and had to
give it to tormund Giantsbane yes
Samwell and bran stark together probably
have the secret to creating new Valyrian
steel
and it's implied that it's a mixture of
dragonglass with castle-forged steel
smelted with dragon fire and maybe some
blood magic but I'm not gonna hold my
breath for Gendry creating new Valyrian
steel it would be awesome though if he
does that during the season but let me
know in the comments if you think we'll
see some of those missing balerion steel
weapons on the TV show during season 8
I'll be posting more bonus videos to get
ready for season 8 episode 1 before this
weekend so leave all your big questions
in the comments if there's special
videos that you want me to make
congratulations to the winner from my
last big giveaway Jared Talbot please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details click here for
my non-spoilery breakdown of all the
early reviews reactions and details from
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1 and
click here for my season 8 top 10 death
predictions thank you so much for
watching
we're almost there congratulations
everybody you made it just a couple more
days to go